I'll be getting dinner ready tonight
before so I wake up about four half four
in the morning do me meditation for an
hour not an hour oh my gosh you can stay
focused for that long exactly that's
your problem one hour and I do half past
four in the morning and then I will
start getting the clothes will be sorted
from the night before dinner be ready
for the night before Pearl knows that my
thing is cooked by nine o'clock in the
morning
and while they're doing this cooking the
kids are dressed the wash and they're
dressed and then we will have breakfast
together
and then I might have to take them out
or do some kind of work with them that
go in the garden and do bits in the
garden then it's lunch then it's
painting then it's crossed and you've
got to clear up
and then you've got to think about
calming down everybody have dinner
together you still get the washing up
you still got the washing to do you
still got the housework to do and
get the kids ready for bed sort out
dinner for the next day spend time with
your husband and still gotta give him
good sex